So Simon Harris is officially T shock,
meaning he's the youngest T shock island has ever had,
beating Lee of Rudger's previous record by 11 months.
Part of his new gig
means that a few other Fin Gael titties are getting a promotion.
So while you may be used to seeing him
as the minister for further and Higher Education,
it's gonna be replaced by this guy.
I should go, Donovan.
But it's not all sunshine and rainbows for our new T shock,
as a poll by the journal and Arnold Things
has found that 23% of 18 to 34 year olds
are less likely to vote for Finn Gail
of the European elections
now that he's leader of the party.
Despite being dubbed the TikTok T shock,
it seems Harris may have given 18 to 34 year olds the Ich.
So what do you think of Simon Harris becoming T shock?
Let us know in the comments
and you can keep up to date with all of the latest politic stories
over on the journal.